il m'est arrivé tellement de situations
assez grave à cause de l'alcool quoi
c'est à dire qu'il ya des moments où
j'ai complètement perdu la mémoire et je
me suis retrouvé dans des boîtes de nuit
etc
j'ai dit on encore des doutes sur ce qui
m'est arrivé j'avais l'impression que ça
faisait partie d'un personnage un peu de
super héroïne et et que je suis cool
avec mes copines et qui ont défoncé les
garçons et que met en fête le soir après
des fois ce dont je pleurais le
lendemain j'étais fragile avait toujours
beaucoup bu en fait parce que j'ai
toujours été dans l'excès j'ai quelqu'un
qui a toujours été dans l'excès et donc
l'alcool faisait partie de mes excès
avant il ya eu la drogue et la cigarette
voilà j'avais du mal à me contrôler et
je pense que voilà ça c'est venu
progressivement je me suis rendu compte
des dégâts que ça faisait dans ma vie et
puis un jour je me suis fait licencier
et puis là je bougeais plus de chez moi
et je buvais tout seul et je buvais pour
voir quoi et puis la saveur là plus rien
du tout de flamboyant deal de chic ou de
quoi que ce soit et et là je me suis
vraiment rendu compte qu'il y avait un
problème
j'ai écrit ce livre justement pour dire
que en fait il n'y avait pas d
alcoolisme en fait il n'y avait pas les
gens qui buvaient juste part parce
qu'ils sont bons vivants et flamboyant
et puis il ya les autres qui sont les
alcoolo quoi en fait c'est vraiment une
erreur et puis c'est une façon de se
planquer qu'est ce que je trouve
extrêmement limite c'est à dire que moi
en fait effectivement je présente bien
j'ai pas du tout la tête de l'emploi
c'est vrai que si on me compare à un mec
qui au pastis à 9 heures du matin
visuellement c'est pas la même chose et
pour autant l'alcool m'a sans doute fait
autant souffrir et même physiquement m'a
autant attaqué que cet homme là je pense
que l'alcool c'est beaucoup pour
beaucoup l'apprentissage la masculinité
et la féminité en fait on se construit
beaucoup des jeunes à travers
l'alcool en fait parfois sans s'en
rendre compte on a l'impression que
c'est ce qui nous rend plus forts on a
l'impression que c'est ce qui nous aide
à tenir à aimer et c est moi je pense
que ç'a vraiment été le cas ce serait
pas pareil pour toutes les femmes
mais je peux parler pour moi est en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est que l'alcool
est très lié à ma féminité
j'ai très jeune j'ai des problèmes à
être une femme parce que l'on m'a
collées beaucoup d'étiquettes que
j'aimais pas et j'avais envie d'être son
genre et du coup j'ai bu un peu pour
détruire qu'il était pour détruire cette
féminité là il ya beaucoup de femmes
quand même qu'ils boivent pas ce que l
on a l'impression d'être les fautives
moi c'était le cas par exemple c'est à
dire que entre la pression qu'on mettait
au travail entre tous les choses qu'on
disait tout le temps d'être aussi été
trop ça machin moi je rentre une soirée
avec une envie c'était de vrais tam et à
la gueule quoi et je le faisais tout
seul josé avec des copines et en fait je
pense que les femmes au lieu de deux
pendant longtemps et surtout avant le
mythe ou en fait au lieu de blâmer le
système oppressif
elle cède là mais elle même et l'alcool
faisait partie des mauvais médicament
qu'elle utilisait à quoi ces normes
qu'il faut déconstruire en fait c'est
débile mémoire par exemple ça me
rassurait beaucoup de voir des femmes à
l'écran qui buvaient tout seul parce que
je me disais à elles sont cools et
boivent bien il faut la même chose quoi
il faut des meufs subversive qui boivent
pas et et qu'on se dise ah bah tiens
en fait on peut être subversif 100 pieds
collés quoi